hello welcome to the buns on podcast
this is manny licky you've tuned in for
a great episode we got Matt fulchiron
back on the podcast do some silly stuff
after the podcast we went to a bar and
watch the football game and we all bet
money on it and hey what's that it was a
good time I mean you I guess you think
about that while we while you're
listening to it because you now you know
the future of this podcast you know
exactly where we end up Matt lost 50
bucks I 150 bucks think Brendan lost a
little bit of money to anyways some
reminders got to remind y'all some stuff
go to bones own podcast calm and if
you're going to buy anything off of
amazon click on the amazon link and and
then buy stuff on amazon we get a little
bit of a kick back for guiding you to
amazon we've just got our first check in
the mail and it's helping us it's
helping us pay for things like the phone
sex calls and different different things
not just that it's not just supporting
our phone sex call addiction but that's
one thing that's helping with also if
you want to buy a live bone zone poster
the poster that was made for when we did
the podcast in boston those are for sale
on our website as well as our bones own
t-shirts if you don't have one of those
yet and i have my my lid key hats up
there I just got both colors back in
stock the beanie is just in time for
winter and if you want to drop some coin
on a baseball hat those are there for
you as well I'm going to be on the road
a little bit this month I'm beginning of
next month as well November twelfth i'll
be in north carolina carrboro north
carolina i believe it's near chapel hill
at the cat's cradle Joe Zimmerman and I
are there I think it's some sort of
benefit show but it's pretty big VIN you
know it'll be fun it's gonna be a great
show to put on by new belgium brewing
and so there should be some good beers I
think there's a distillery involved so
come have some good drinks and I watched
a good comedy show if you live out there
week after that November 20th i'll be in
tulsa oklahoma glad to go back there the
great people at the blue whale comedy
festival are setting up a one-nighter
for me at the American Theatre Company
day after that the 21st of November i'll
be in dallas at sons of hermann hall
Brooks Wheelan and I co-headlining and
November 22nd i'll be in houston for
whatever fest then a couple weeks after
that december third through sixth i'll
be in cincinnati at go bananas go to lid
key no dang it go to randy dash lid keep
calm I just changed my website used to
be a lid ki randi wish I had just read
Randy looky regular Randy litke but some
son of a [__] in Canada owns it and I
met him and he won't give it to me all
right I think that's about it the song
i'm playing in the intro is one of one
of the bands i really like right now
they're called timber timber and the
second timber spelled differently t IM
BR e the first one spelled regularly
it's a band from canada super swampy
music it's good i really enjoy it check
them out alright enjoy the episode
melon podcast I'm meeting a melon me the
whole [__] thing I'm already hit
that's only a third of it I'm gonna eat
this whole container yeah when I finish
that I'll go get another container and a
bud light thats cool bud light's my new
drink of choice really what he's no not
really huh he used to drink the silver
bullet yeah I was a Coors guy but you
know what I just has more flavor it does
true I used to think that coors light
was best because it's frost brewed yeah
but i really like miller lite because
it's triple filtered yeah well and it's
a cold that's the coldest beer i think a
bud also regular bud and bud light has
the born on date so you know how that's
good fresh it is yeah I like my beer
fresh yeah I like it fresh I do i still
like frost brewed beer but i like the
triple filter not cold filtered or maybe
it's cold filter I'm kind of a fan of
bud ice bud ice yeah oh that's good
going a while a little more kick what's
the ice phenomenon it's like they they
more alcohol yeah um they must freeze it
a little bit or something you know what
I don't want and this some [__]
Hollywood [__] invited me out the
other night which is nice you know I
have a lot of Hollywood [__] friends
but he want to eat sushi I was like no
thanks oh god I don't want rakesh yeah
raw fish are you kidding me [__] that
and then he's like we're gonna go to a
microbrew place or one of these [__]
loud like oh okay Oh what is that some
fancy microbrewed like oh ten percent
amber hops or whatever thank ya I don't
want my beer tasting like chocolate
peanut butter thank you yeah it's brewed
by some where's the FDA that's what I
wanted that's a good idea good questions
that's not you know Bud Miller Coors all
the great ones the people who invented
it games anything that tastes like corn
syrup and water that's good to know i
mean yeah [__] all this stuff we have to
look at a menu
soda or coors light man yeah yeah no
Coors lights good i'm not saying Coors
lights bad I'm just saying bud light is
kind of what I'm into lately I just
think it's got a better taste yeah like
the color of the can has a more colors
well I have football you can get there
your team yeah what I think I think of
next that's they have cans for every
team do you like in Coors when when it
gets cold enough to mountains turn blue
oh I love those do that yeah on the
bottle of my chinos hold and drink or a
bird could drink it at that that's
that's a bird could drink it at that
point birds we were talking about this
earlier birds have to have really cold
liquids maybe we should call a pet store
and ask how cold yeah our beer should be
that we give our bird we should
definitely put somebody on the spot yeah
we got a mob we can we found those uh
the bird the parrot videos of the
Pirates and stuff just I'm 1 i'm sure
there's a million though yeah you have
them saying like give me a beer or
something or i could just do that i
guess yeah just do it yeah for the bird
expert well no that's just you know the
best thing to do is go right before you
say anything ah crazy dude do you are
you follow football Matt know I've been
trying the past few years to get into it
I don't know who are dead on sorry bud
light I really just like drinking I've
started watching the games gives me an
excuse go to the ball tonight I think so
let's do it all right let's watch um
let's get ready to shed on it though
yeah I don't know who to bet on who's
place thursday night football it's the
ASEAN Hawks playing times that start
probably pretty early five ish yeah
right when this is over yeah dude go
Hawks Oh everybody's gonna know I mean
should I bet the Seahawks I mean that's
what I minus sick because i have i'm a
fan don't think about it just serves
both nine well you see here's the thing
and i don't i'm not very learn it on
gambling but i do know like that they
have equal and those of you listening
yeah we recorded this a few weeks ago so
why ya can don't pay us go [__]
unfuck yourself yeah [__] yeah
[__] go stick your head back in the
toilet continue bobbing for your mom's
turn
yeah do what you were already doing and
let us flash over here stupid
underground living [__] ugly piece of
troll [__] yeah you [__] diarrhea
slick [__] oh what's that nothin
remix headphone yeah keep it give me uh
give me a little reverb you want a
little a little verb yeah you [__]
vaginal secretion of [__] diarrhea
out of a dead lady's ass Oh Marie
Antoinette you [__] Marie Antoinette
spiderweb bug-eating [__] suck
it that's all I needed yeah our fans
[__] blow [__] you hey if you're
listening to this what the [__] were you
go kick it Annie hey you know why did
you check this out yeah I'm gonna tweet
let's just [__] have our fans call in
and just tell them the [__] off yeah
let's do that okay let me don't tweet it
quite yet yeah yeah now some of you
listening maybe like oh I'm my calls
coming up cuz you already know what
happens that's the crazy thing you're
listening it's now and you already know
what's about to happen even though we
haven't done it yet yeah blood pressures
up yeah really they know more than we
know yeah they're from the future oh
[__] even though the dumbest ugliest
[__] sometimes I somehow
neuronal of [__] knowledge popped in
their brain somehow yeah [__] idiots
uh well the the you know the type of
fans i hit the most what the loyal ones
the blonde girl ones that have big
honkers yeah that's annoying sometimes
they try to [__] you hook up with you on
the Internet yeah whoo good you imagine
even watching one of our fear no no not
even with someone else's to boy uh
what's our number 323 actually let's not
say it because people call once they
listen talk doesn't they don't get it
even though you just exciting it like if
you do this it doesn t what's not it's
not all of them are
we're not here so what do you guys have
like a burner or something it's like
just for it's a google number that I
rear out through a skype channel that's
the only way to because if you just do
Google you can hear the phone ring every
single time someone calls so you have to
pay for a skype number and it gets
forward it's so annoying flowers whoever
calls in let's offer him some melon this
is delicious the melons good no we're
just gonna tell him the [__] off ok good
[__] you I think I have a draft saved
with our number in it nor me to tweet it
out and then have you retweet it um you
know this just going to tug on it 989 oh
uh i thought was 969 no it won't get
ugly because we have all the control ok
uh actually know that we're gonna tell
him the [__] off and we'll tell you what
we see him and we'll tell you to [__]
off I feel like they like you guys
they're gonna come after me I feel like
they won't have a chance don't even tell
him you just get to say [__] you yeah go
call my name you say whatever nasty
things like this is gonna be a therapy
session alright sounds fun should we
play the theme song for sure mmm no okay
well great let's not let's not do it
let's not do it
Oh
you
hey how do you like that [__] no I'm
gonna get off that you got to hear a lot
of the theme song there and then we got
down to the part where it breaks down a
little bit where it's like yeah we got
out of hey Randy ready who's this she
says no got down if I break down a
little bit was it me yeah but I do close
to Mike as I just turned the game down a
little bit on mine who's this because
this who's this I just turned the game
down a little bit on you know what
that's Randy right yeah our low end was
all [__] up because we did that
podcast it wasn't [__] up but it was
just on the last people adding a lot
yeah just like a slightly different
member when we're doing the live one in
a Boston in the yellow and was too hard
I felt like the last couple that we've
done sounded a little flat like not as a
rich yeah rich but creamy I like just a
few just a quick turn of the knob not
bad all right so I tweeted out sweetie
hopefully like my grandma doesn't color
something oh [__] are you doing this
I'll get this Matt I don't know you know
how we get to that point in your
podcasting career oh I don't know why do
anything exactly uh uh so [__] do you
like Dave Grohl yes I do who doesn't
right oh yeah I mean he was in nirvana
yeah he's the [__] best well plenty
of [__] so get this um we're getting a
call I'll tell you after this all right
I want to hear the whole from danny
growling well except press one to send a
voicemail press Q hello who's this hey
this is dan Grimes how you guys doing
[__] [__] [__] dick [__] idiot
succubus to [__] ask your mom dick Oh
what do you [__] eating turns out of
a toilet oh that it's a call boo
specifically say
q tan Grande no because now man yeah
you're not gonna get me what you mean
good i own a phone number nicholas you
stupid hey hold on who's this day crimes
right [__] stupid brooch you're
an idiot all right next caller call from
Dallas oh okay I get it I can't the
color voice MIT good sounds like an
[__] Oh way up on him I think we miss
you even better yeah [__] you Alex nice
try pal alright so we're probably gonna
call pretty soon hope get another call
mm-hmm hopefully I need just pay
attention to make sure it's not the same
people let's actually Matt you answer
okay like answer nice or what yeah
answer nice and be like okay who's this
uh what do you wanna talk about I think
you're like a call talat Oh Alex again
hey hey you've reached the the bone zone
Alex yeah hey you're on the bones on
buddy how are you good man how are you
guys good good uh Brandon and Randy
wanted to tell you something though [__]
you Alex [__] [__] you [__] [__]
out a good [__] monkey brain piece of
[__] [__] idiot oh I smell like [__]
MA arms oh look scoop oh thanks for
listening to our podcast idiots at the
gala me you can't do anything else Oh
Ron eediot go [__] your mother go
[__] dick some cat turds out of your
stupid cats litter box and [__] to
stick them up your own ass that's a
stupid bro dis guys stupid or yet you
guys want to hear my dog bark yeah yeah
actually okay yeah watch what I thought
you're gonna do a dog bark oh okay
that's good that's for good luck you
hated hey Who am I hey can someone help
me throw my shoes don't know
this is like yeah yeah Alex yeah [__]
hung up stupid I logo voila we were get
another caller we messed it's awfully
they call back in a second you brought
something something from when we had
your birthday at Dave & Buster's oh cuz
this is uu KU zhu zhu possessing i guess
that gurgurk is he forcer prism
wrestling yeah that's good burp Gurkhas
easy we are very catchy don't remember
the word I don't need it do you want to
find that the clip of that show but
Martha's on we can play it for uh uh
yeah oh here we go oh god Paul from Alex
wait no so I didn't number I'm the boy's
name right then it's his dogs phone hey
is this the same guy hey hey is this
alex a different guy Oh different Alex
did you already talk you that uh we had
a different Alison no Alex he was a
total idiot oh no I'm the cool Oh Nick
[__] you are just a new clock guess who
it is it's a [__] stupid idiot hello
you're no way maybe your mom's in a bone
who is this
who is this hello who is this hello who
is this hello speak you idiot dumb ass
[__] Stu I'm a guy that does i'm
working at the [__] vill station no
gegege Gieger i got you buddy this guy's
an idiot yeah I don't drink the oil that
you're changing yeah i'm at a fryer and
[__] jiffy lube yeah click hung up oh
the other person still and hold one tom
yeah yeah that guy's an idiot hey we're
back could you still story oh wait maybe
they hung up yeah god but he's still an
idiot not us yeah i got this matt yeah
dave grohl like I we have I know I have
mutual friends with him he wants to do
the podcast oh my god Randy won't
doesn't want him to why not this it's
nuts different than that it's different
than why why wasn't he on last week when
I kept emailing you Randy can you call
up so we can call you an idiot no I mean
this is something that he always will
only he won't speak to me off the
podcast he only wants to bring it up on
the podcast okay whenever I want to talk
to him about the you know the issue of
dave grohl be on the pine table you know
what I think it's a great idea but we
just need to talk about it why do we
need to talk about our getting it this
guy was in nirvana he played drums in
Iran's might be someone who's already
called and Randy's like I never want to
talk about this one I guess but he
doesn't [__] returned my email gone
hopefully Dave Cole hi my name hey nice
nice name where do you think of that uh
[__] in the bathroom yeah would you
pull that from the backside of a [__]
truck your [__] truck covers hey I'm
the most unoriginal name known to man
oh [__] head toilet throughout the Lotus
jugs yo Joe yes hi my name is joe i'm
[__] [__] caller hey joe how's it
going oh how did you add you know what I
sounded like we discussed because you're
so [__] stupid [__] you stop
listening to podcasts yeah [__] it's
over i don't want [__] like you
listening to our podcast they go hole in
your back yard stick your head in it
fill it in with dirt and die pal [__]
you suck it yeah we used to do that I
used to coffee more thumb to suck it or
that people in my you got guys are mean
man oh yeah we're premise this far I'm
sorry you must not have a brain because
that's what we told you we were gonna do
and now you're all surprised by occupies
[__] idiot suck a dick yeah you're
stupid dude um Joey honest I'm you
listen to our podcast your [__] so just
go job there let's trade if you died I'd
be uh I'd [__] be happy now I don't
know maybe I wouldn't even know I were
getting another call from Ron oh this
guy oh hello I'm Brian oh hey what's up
dummy I'm a half of a brand okay only
have a half of a brain because the other
half I [__] ate cuz I'm fat and
stupid I ate my own brain [__] you Brian
suck a dick Brian oh yeah eater [__]
shirt guys yeah buy more [__] are you
wearing it inside out and backwards cuz
you're so [__] do this guy's good
[__] you bad [__] well guess what hey
you know you should do now with your
[__] unemployment check by a [__]
poster from the from the from the
website oh yeah we're selling some stuff
and then after that does uh you get blow
me up comp can we build you up come blow
them up Tom it's the old reference to an
old show I don't know
that is Tom like it's this guy's an
idiot get rid of me is that what do you
need egg you had it let's go sit back
one question I don't even notice got to
see careful be careful because it's a
nice to him sound like a hate crime if
it gets to be too much what's your real
name dude my real name is Stephen hmm
suck it Stephen man okay there's just be
silent picks up
Hey Oh what's up dick suck a dick man
gotcha you have been gotten it's like
reverse prank call mmm we bring the
calls to us so you gonna bet that bet on
the Hawks I wanna bet on the 14 I can't
blame me 49ers with six and a half seems
like a safe route 49 I don't think about
this stuff I just pick mmm I don't know
it's good like we might have overthought
it yeah you have so by seattle i'll give
you I'll give you fifty dollars to put
on the Hawks I got cash on me all right
I want I mean I was for me though it's
not for you yeah yeah so if you lose you
just give me 50 bucks yeah if you win
I'll give you whatever though yeah like
150 yeah fifty dollars sit I used to
have one of these accounts like cancel
cuz I got too aggressive and I guess all
my money no no I'm gonna gamble through
Brit this will slow it down yeah I've
been on a good little streak lately yeah
um okay alright you wanna bet i believe
i play 50 on san francisco or you come
with that so you just do it 50 on each
team that's funny put more on one of
them yeah yeah and you guys are
comfortable with the points you're
giving six and a half points it's have
to win by seven yeah mm-hmm and then
what I gotta win by nothing just 10 you
can lose by six points all right
yeah I get it um all right I know what
I'm doing so obviously um so give my 50
bucks dude like Dave Grohl can I get a
receipt ideas are also we're gonna punch
you in the face in hockey ah so you
don't know what the game is happening
Dave Grohl like committed had an open
three day window yeah and i did email
randy is dave grohl i emailed Randy and
Dave Grohl's assistant Randy never got
the emails or never replied to the email
said eating good God fun God now we had
to yell at this guy who pardon me Who am
I speaking with this is rob okay can you
hold can you hold please you hold rub
I'm holding it right now
you
Purple Rain
if you like the black the black
urban working
all right hung up on the guy was an
[__] [__] you so emailed uh Gabriel
versus we're so brave run up that makes
for a good podcast I don't know either
but you know what do you know eating a
giant cantaloupe and having people call
us we could say [__] you I know it's
pretty good plus there's the bat where
you just play song from I am more place
about it no I got that money on me hello
oh man mmm the guy was such a dick maybe
we should call it business or something
yeah and then do that the diarrhea thing
which I closed that door you want maybe
I should for the listener brendan is
closing a door it's getting out of the
chair you just close the door no he's
walking back to the chair Randy's
[__] girlfriend's here for some
reason why she home from Jed
ok I will call that Claire lady a [__]
the ladies a bit is that your mom Oh
tell your mother I'll go call upon him I
gotta such a [__] yes we call um would
normally 1 i'm here we call it bra store
doing then that alone ah it's a tough
one though I you know the first time I
was here Brendan got really far he got
right to the end of the punch line
before they hung up oh that's right yeah
yeah ribeiro umbrella bra then the last
time I was here the girl stayed on way
too long and really trying to give it to
you yeah but she wasn't that good at it
but she thought she was good at it um
then we can just go into the [__] you
thing if we goes on the right I do enjoy
the call on the phone sex lately ok
let's try this real quick roster nah
it's just a regular store it's like a
clothing store alright so um so Dave
Grohl Dave Grohl's assistant and Randy
we did talk about this off the air when
you still say that you didn't get the
emails but he was there were emails to
me and Randy from Dave girls assistant
said he wants to do the podcast and
October twelfth and thirteenth I think
were any time they say and so what's the
verdict I mean well look at Randy like
makeup they can't believe he's not
listening
oh [__] we get to people thank you for
calling forever 21 phone so modest
computer on help you yeah hey this is
John hi John are you looking at speak to
someone huh yeah um where's the broad
apartment say that one more time I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm meeting a melon um
I'm looking to buy a bra for my wife hey
brah yeah for my future wife okay ever
you know what I mean may send you what's
the biggest bra you have what's the
biggest bra you carry give me one second
okay thank you hurry up John really
dropped the ball on that almost worked
really good that would've been real good
yeah John [__] yeah um should we I'm
okay wafer call from Lisa this is to
accept press one to send a voice mule
sale exactly hey Lisa hello yeah hey i'm
on the phone with a bra store oh hey
yeah yeah hello yep put them okay i want
to let you know it's going to take a
couple of minutes we're gonna go back
there and chuck okay what do you know
like ballpark with the biggest my wife
is on the phone with me right now we're
checking sizes right now well someone
wants to go check okay what's the
biggest prob ever seen in your life um
in my life yeah in a proper 21 or like
just a really big boobs I need help like
finding a really big bra the biggest
ones we have I believe our DS that's
what she wants to go Chuck right now
okay um but is there like a way you guys
can put multiple ones of them like
together I've seen that before and she's
like some really bad things happen i
have like really big boobs we've never
done not here to be honor what's the
biggest i've had it what's the biggest
understand you have you don't because my
what's the biggest underpant joke
because my wife's
big all around she wants to go Chuck's
so it's going to take a couple of
minutes okay hurry up you do it you're
doing great Lisa is Lisa Stallone yay
wait well I'm you're on hold with
forever 21 Lisa okay cool and you're
doing great thanks who are you a bit by
the way who are you Lisa do you really
you really have actually big boobs know
where do you live take it I'm from
Chicago mmm sorry that you're a loser
town when it comes to baseball teams
must be rough oh I live next to Wrigley
Field I'm so glad that they lost oh geez
that's why they lost all that negativity
what's a big gay area over there uh yeah
next to boy Spanish yeah it is um do uh
how old are you I'm 24 hmm yeah we're
here hello yes hi we actually our
biggest I've of the 36 d what about bra
let's do you guys have bigger bra let's
we we might have a few but those would
be like small medium large not xxo how
big is a large what I what I bar you I
don't really know or I just had like
your event spelling lately and so like
I'm trying to find something that I
actually like hold all of mine yeah I
repertory contemporary solon HS b and
the largest don't really fit my boobs
there are too small like I like are
brought let's run smaller that makes
sense how big are your boobs I have a 30
60 B isn't boy no the oven dog wow you
got honey right yeah they're really
small you're so lucky yeah mosquito bite
titties that's what i call that yeah no
I like if you
Oh honestly like if you want to Broadway
I would go to we have like stairs and
hmm i have some an urban outfitters
actually has them i got mine from there
before but Evan outfitters is made to
baby pastas there's no way I'd be able
too many clothes nor am I like over
talking you guys now I feel bad no I
mean it's perfect I'd some farts and
played diarrhea oh it sounded like
static oh no no so they can't even tell
it I was like oh no you can't were you
guys calling now we're still on hold at
the same place what do you do how long
you guys been on the go we don't tell
her to [__] oh [__] yeah yeah yep well
Lisa you know she's gonna pass the test
is there anything else you guys needed
Lisa I'm not really okay we're gonna sue
you by the way so get ready I'm gonna
sue you personally not the company bye
goodbye my dear have a nice day oh you
hang up on both of them no that was a
forever 21 it's weird like when someone
actually wants to help yeah in this
situation where whatever there's gotta
be there all day I'll tell Lisa [__] you
[__] you Lisa yeah Lisa are you [__]
idiot
[__] Lisa [__] you lock you you're the
worst type of person Lisa [__]
[__] where do you work what do you
do for a living hey dummy I'm talking to
ISA how does she hang up did she met up
and hang up maybe call from Chris oh I
like the sounds of this guy already I
now thanks Chris I eat my own poop
because i'm stupid as shoot my name
could be a boy's name / girl named [__]
you Chris what's your on Don yeah no
it's the wrong number [__] yeah
everyone as much as hey I know you're
coming to whatever fest but hey me and
how come you never come to Houston and
that's a shitty Duncan Trussell
impression so that was my shitty Brendon
Walsh doing Duncan Trussell impression
ah thank you Chris I hope I never meet
you I actually got an offer from a place
called the joke joint in Houston you
should come down there no Sam Bailey I
look you know I know if you listen to
common christinas your mom house but
they're here quite a bit okay what's uh
what's a good venue there that's not a
comedy club um like an actual theater
well I mean let's not go crazy something
that holds like you know 150 people like
a rock club or something where you would
see like where does Tom perform when he
goes there he performs at warehouse
lives they have a small room that holds
that i'd say probably under to hunt like
150 people were also Fitzgerald's and
both of those are not comedy clubs a lot
Fitzgerald's I've been there with
Stanhope yeah Fitz job is great and a
warehouse live has a side room oh shut
up yeah really okay today so I needed a
cue so I needed goodbye bottom
[__] that guy that was real helpful
actually because I should I haven't been
to houston in forever so uh pretty good
uh I've been there once yeah i watch the
UFC anchor well didn't you go to
somebody's I don't festival is coming up
oh that's what he was calling it up oh
hi I love to fart and rude oh I'm sorry
man this is brendan i'm actually the
nice one here but Randy and Matt Fulcher
honor just being jerks great well sorry
dude I what do you what are you calling
about when I would talk about I try to
make it to boston but i terminated I one
closer to the next call Robert hey who's
this this is brendan this is Robert what
are you calling about sorry Randy's
gonna tell you to [__] off but just
ignore em girl kitty to you what do you
what's up what's going on man what's
correct what's been going on with you
can you tell what that noises [__] you
I'm gonna go get the rest of that melon
um Mel and hus I wonder what the fart
sound like on the other end you know I
I'll call in yeah let's try it out I'll
call in I'll go into the other room and
see why the farts okay maybe when it's
too loud it probably sounds United mean
yeah it's nice and loud it just sounds
like I can't imagine it sounded anything
other than a big fart yeah huh let's see
all right I wonder what its gonna sound
like those on speaker oh I wonder what
name is gonna call from to accept press
one to send a voicemail [__] you Randy
whoa hello it's me ready oh we're trying
to figure out what the fart sound well
[__] you Randy
sounds like I'm constantly [__] let's
do it sound get into it let's get into
it let's make a soundscape you imagine
what Dave Grohl can do with this dude
yeah we're gonna talk about David play a
beat behind
you
holy my brain
go to the phone yeah
you
caller you're on
stuff I can't hear you
are you still there hello well hey Randy
hey Walt check this out uh yeah I'd say
that sounds like farts okay as far as I
can tell that's a shame Lisa hung up she
sounded promising 24 years old all right
do you have a girlfriend no nice oh
we're getting a call oh that's right
hang up maybe we'll meet one give-give
Lisa's not in alone Oh
Oh
hello hello all up hello can you guys
tell me can you do me a favor hello
hello hello is this hey ro ro that's
your name yeah
so what's up bro uh row row row your
boat gently down three keep it you got a
row your boat
hey ro that's a good one that's really
good hey do you wanna can you do can do
the screams with two screams the man and
the woman okay with the reverb no
request row do you want to step into the
rant corner row do you want to set
stepped out of the rant room do you want
to step into the ramp corner yeah oh
yeah can we do the red corner yeah you
have something that's chopping your ass
oh yeah I could politely is the right
corner more polite than the rant room
there is no rant room yeah you [__]
idiot Randy's on the phone I'm on the
phone cool hey Randy good to see it here
you what's up I'm on the phone um you
were living hitting job to really
interesting to hear you through a little
speaker here okay Freddie this is um we
got what's your name row round right now
gentlemen welcome to the bone zone
he's stepping into the red corner today
we gotta call her his name's row and
he's gonna step into the bone zone drink
corner and tell you what Japanese ass
cells with chap your ass bro I can't
send a character named eros imagine
being here can you hear row row your
boat member 30 laughing at you just keep
laughing [__] you bye-bye yo you can't
turn it miles on it eat [__] like it
suck it suck it up get up get up get up
get up get up get up get up get up get
up get we get up get hey check this out
yeah I made you know I make songs right
Randy uh-huh my phone way too so we
gotta keep ourselves on your phone oh oh
yeah that's no put it so the speaker's
facing this one yeah so now that the
show the others away maybe we could just
do a pretty dope soundscape yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah micro yeah I think row I don't
think that was even though name it
wasn't he's trying to get a joke at a
row row okay here's uh here's a song i
was working on earlier and here's one
there's always a version of me starting
the stronger than I yell at my
girlfriend oh yeah so here's here's the
one where she interrupts me
sorry if you try [__] [__] all right and
here's the first that's called your home
from bingo except craft one to send a
voicemail but one could send a voicemail
y'all trifling yo trifling y'all travel
in y'all travel in yo chocolate ok then
there's a second version goddammit
that's my girl in
let's make a super d
yah yah yah
hold on
he ain't messin with no bro
No
Oh
no everything's are always right and
didn't knows everything and he's always
knows everything he's always right
strange
so
three
superstar
yo chapter are you trying I'm cycle card
fun are you trifling dude are you
trifling yeah tell us oh who is this
your car look [__] you [__] you hey [__]
you bro Carlos cute girls like you you
trifle we don't need you we don't need
anybody show you so much [__] you what
I'm gonna do sucks it up listening to
the podcast oh we're scared o.o those
one less idiot listening to our [__]
great podcast we don't need you he'll
need you we don't need you guys no [__]
you don't even know not for later
[__] Matt full Charles here what do
you gotta do what you gotta say to map
Voltron for tron [__] you Carlos ain't
[__] Carlos Tom little fun for trying
[__] you [__] you my [__] come over here
and suck my why do you come over here
spit spit on his dog motor car come on
there come on over here come over here
336 south Alexandria Avenue 900 20 that
ring I address apartment 3 yeah come on
over pal I'm gonna come over did you
know you like imma [__] all yours
worse care of it we're not about waiting
you think so [__] okay sounds good
yeah that sounds cool yeah so uh come on
watch the game f yeah yeah yeah we'll
see you soon karma three ya alright pal
we gotta get bring some beer yeah yeah
see you man yeah see if really do you
[__] face somebody suck a dick call oh
look you can what an [__] alright so
50 on the Hawks 50 on the Niners yeah
who you gonna bet on I still don't know
we got until 5 25 whoo that's coming oh
[__] that is coming where you want to
watch it watch it here or at a bar you
know what's not bad that barbarella
place let you know why it's [__]
quiet they got TVs and they do it don't
copy our no chicks allowed that's good
with happy hour prices is about regular
yeah regular price of its day with fer
prices wells a Libyan is still
unaffordable 50 ok seattle seahawks
you're betting 50 to win 45 dollars and
forty-five cents so after the 50 if you
win i give you forty five dollars and
forty-five cents if you lose you give me
fifty dollar what's how much do you have
to bet so i make 50 so i win fifty
dollars uh probably like six cuz i'm
gonna win oh you know what i want to
make it easy on you to pay me it's funny
i know i'm gonna lose but i'm not gonna
change my bad you have to bet $55 to win
50 all right let's do it 55 the way when
you pay me it's just easier you know Amy
45-7 that 45 cents you know he's not
gonna pay yeah I know then I'll get
ripped off in the end 55 mad butcher
wrong you know that song no we were just
in Boston with that guy oh really yeah
we went and he's filming a movie me and
brendan are in it no [__] yeah I think I
heard him talking about that yeah one of
your podcast yeah yeah he made that song
and I played on my podcast i [__]
love it yeah I guys great if you didn't
notice Oh other words Matt it was
actually kind of hard to notice because
there's all sorts a lot of noise I was
what I didn't notice yeah that's a hard
hot gas to listen to it is uh Matt
actually listens to our podcast I domes
crazy that's cool yeah crazy man Duncan
[__] I laugh out loud yeah let me
call in so do you want yours to be do
you want to win 52 why don't we do that
you'll bend
no no it's all instincts I wanted 50 on
San Francisco know that I'm saying do
you want to bet 55 as well to win 50 I
don't want you have five dollars is
important ok I won't change anything on
your your bedding fifty dollars to win
45 45 45 40 that's what I want is my
lucky number for all right I have
changed to you like you'd ever is 45 45
you don't got the 45 cents you know
you'll get it to me eventually we live
in the same I got changed i'll see you
at gelson's that's right Yunel since the
most over price you know I saw okay
Bryce what up you notice the prices went
up I was gone every designed if prices
went up really I saw a distal barbarella
of grocery stores that's the appeal
again since there's nobody in there and
it's it gets pretty crowded but there's
some there's some [__] milfy ass
[__] and yoga pants up in that
store sign I needs to work in that I
never wanted to go to that grocery store
cuz i knew i would run into like five
people that I customers of mine true I'm
a Thai masseuse are you yeah that I used
to give a hot stone massage he would
massage their tie yeah neckties yeah
dude get the wrinkles out get although
yeah all the attention of neckties it's
eight dollars for lettuce at Gelson's
yeah I like the day you know the deli
you know that's that's what keeps me
coming back in the hot food bar if your
guys I like to [__] think ahead like
when you're driving passing you're like
oh right I'm starving I haven't eaten
since yesterday at noon it's a home
phone over God way back that's one to
spend a voicemail press two
yeah well just about done so okay I got
you guys down yeah microwave 54 you 50
or 55 for you but if I do an affinity
for that and then I'm gonna have to find
out who I should bet on this is actually
bad because we're gonna go to the bar
and like I'm gonna be rooting for once I
know that I know that's not good is it
Oh am i a bum dumb it's all right yeah
but I think good okay that's fine
because then it's like like I've you
should be good man I won't get mad I
won't get mad I'll get sad that I lost
my I won't get mad that you won money
I'm right here about that ok now it's
not betting is cuz I want to get into
football and this is the best way to get
into football Oh totally that's why i
opened it up cuz i have friends who like
football and so you just open an account
throw a few hundred bucks in there play
with it three years you eat some ribs
drinks now you're having a good subs
sucks like dicks yeah right sucking dick
neck balls ego dick neck yeah oh dude
did I take blow on it from the side so
you know Randy's dog elk neck right yeah
elk neck and he's how is he is he still
in the animal hospital no he's out and
he's just got a big cone around his than
his neck his daughters it's rough I
didn't say he's upstairs oh he's
upstairs on a big bed oh yeah I'm not
big better oh yeah uh la neck really big
fight with was it raccoons or something
it was it was a possum oh I bet i'm
actually laying with a pop did you know
that meant that Randy's got like four
Dobermans no I didn't know any about any
of his pets I I blah i am in part of
this Doberman forum but it's only for
guys who weigh over 400 pounds yeah so
it's like guys who weigh over 400 pounds
and have Dobermans and I kind of helped
run the forum there okay yeah that makes
sense because I way I way well over 400
pounds I'm in the 500s and I have three
Dobermans so it's perfect for me what
sounds like fun I only wish I could join
ya well gets get some Dobermans and it's
Melanie helped gain a lot yeah I know
your loot that takes more where do they
say it takes more
is to burn it then 3y test it yeah when
you eat melon you lose weight oh you
lose weight yeah like celery it takes
more callicott it be workout calories
it's a digest it that's what most foods
that you're keeping your eye on the
phone to make sure nobody's calling yeah
no one's calling but with most foods
it's that way it it it you burn more
calories than it then the food has in it
gotcha so it's really hard to gain any
weight if you just eat melon boy most
there's a lot most foods or that way
especially vegetables but not know yes
not McDonald's McDonald's some of the
stuff they have is it's got the services
and stuff in it mcDonald's has a new
thing called ants on a log is there a
celery with peanut butter and raisins
yeah I saw that on the yo and that's
they've replaced a lot of items with
just that cuz it's easier for them to
mass produce now that a breakfast food
or is that well they've breakfast all
day so yeah yeah good do you eat that do
you eat at McDonald's mad I try not to
but when I do I love it yeah really but
what I don't feel a lot better the only
time I've eaten at it recently is from
at the airport well yeah me and you had
yeah that's the only time I've had
mcdonalds recently I eat it right before
a flight at 6am because it's like I
didn't eat anything before I left the
house that might have been the first
time I've had mcdonalds in don't know
look a couple the other time was when I
hired that a hired of Britney Spears
look alike to come hang out at my
friend's apartment with me sounds like
fun I was kind of cool and and I Britney
Spears eats mcdonalds like the real real
gangsters so I bought her a bunch of
mcdonalds and and then after afterwards
I ate the big mac that I bought for her
cuz she didn't eat it right it turns out
this look alike was a vegetarian so she
only ate the fries so I ate the Big Mac
so she doesn't go method no not like
Britney oh well she's vegetarian not
vegan yeah cuz you're vegan don't think
you need to fire sorry I mouthful Miller
that's classic
um now we're gonna take phone calls on
this podcast when we start or at some
point yeah I can't wait it's gonna be
fun rip some people a new [__] but uh
yeah it was cool she was cool I got to
watch her change and stuff really yeah
she put on she put on some cool clothes
some kind of like Britney Spears
costumes and stuff that's awesome yeah
just here in her underwear she wore
underwear over her jeans and she was
comfortable coming over she was
comfortable coming over i paid her I
know it's like in a public appearance
yeah I piss in your house it was in my
friend's apartment but they weren't
there [__] yeah we could call a my Pater
I think it was not that much like a
couple hunt ski like no less 75 i think
i paid her like 40 bucks oh my god yeah
but all that McDonald's it's another
like 15 yeah why I got mcdonalds I got
her a big gulp I got her lucky charms
she like cigarettes is I didn't get her
cigarettes I got our lucky charms um
what else Starbucks got our starbucks i
buy to spend a lot of money on food for
I wonder how much it would cost to you
ever get a hooker back no I've never
gotten one but I'm thinking about doing
it oh really yeah especially if I win uh
you know what a fifty dollar hooker dude
no but I have like 95 and forty-five
cents oh no I guess I don't get 50 I bet
now you get it back well not really not
me because you're not really giving it
the IV feels like you so know what's a
good price for a hooker I mean I think
for a decent one 11 grand like maybe 10
grand 35 I mean like the real like
attractive girls either yeah there's a
lot of rich guys man like you know uh if
you know any rich guy like you know like
guys were just like uh ten granny
nothing yeah I like on your but one of
not even yeah so yeah I don't know and
so what do you do you got an escort
service I haven't done it because number
one I know I would feel well I can't
afford it yeah really mainly
but like the times that like you know
that you're like on the road [__]
drunk in your hotel room like well look
at craigslist or one of the like the
back page ad as always terrifying to me
yeah I'm like you know what you're not
getting yeah I it's like you look at it
for a few hours and go you know I'm not
gonna do this and then the escorts like
you kind of gotta go away I got a free
internet no I man you got a date I
always feel like I'd puss out on the
date and not somewhere melon no I'm good
come on I always feel like uh like I let
him off the hook we check it out this is
one of the pictures of the britney
spears girl you have to get up now i
can't spend it too much yeah she don't
look like her at all no really she died
think heard the pictures that i saw
online she was younger but uh somebody
another not talk yeah she eaten see
that's that big mac that I ate oh that's
uh she's too old Shin look anything like
Britney Spears now hey I found her old
picture she's trying to make money as a
Britney Spears look like now she's like
a yoga instructors why don't we put
ourselves on line as look alike for that
I'm like I'll be looking hired for 50
bucks but yeah like I'll be Matt Damon
you be Ben Affleck can we see like will
be freshly see if anybody's out getting
her outfit on alright she looks like
Britney right there no she doesn't not
at all I'll find the one where she looks
like you never over here she goes looks
like a bowling alley ashtray hey come on
yeah Britney Spears hey come on what
it's my friend all right you guys want
to start the podcast or what nah nah
well I do have a hard out well yeah we
all watch this game right and not get my
car towed where's your car I'm not gonna
get towed but it's on the next street
huh six o'clock 530 I'm supposed to be
either okay what we got time six o'clock
it's like ticket time for sure tickets
and then if I get a ticket and it's like
45 bucks and then I don't win then it's
like I lost 90 bucks no it's like I lost
95 bucks cuz I gotta I gotta pay the
piper AKA Brennan Walt lose her doing a
dance routine nobody can see this though
they don't care these idiots they listen
to anything they don't moves that I did
it sounded like a fake story yeah that's
true hey I brought a kazoo I think it's
a cheap kazoo right hell yeah it just
sounds like my voice going him hell yeah
hell yeah that's a cheap cuz it's better
than nothing checa that's not great yeah
that's really cheap dude broke it I know
I smash it against the table and I could
do anymore i'll sell this to Garfunkel
and Oates you know I [__] both of them
Brandi knows that yeah that is really
all that he's [__] both of them I
[__] both Garfunkel and Oates riki
lindhome and and Kate Micucci had sex
with both of them we should shave oh yes
uh Kate and I were just kind of [__]
buddies actually I was kind of [__]
buddies with both of them for a while
never did a threesome that's always
everybody's followers to them but we did
we did a lot of sex lots of comes the
Gazans you get gar funky I used to call
them a gar fuckl and moan loans because
they're both wild in the sack yeah I
heard that so you were loud in bed so
you were together with them I know you'd
have a threesome but no you work at
dating quote unquote data at one time no
just kind of hung out you know was with
cake first and then you know after after
I kind of kicked her to the curb about a
month later started fooling around with
Ricky and real hot and heavy we did it
there amy schumer i banked her a lot of
female comedians mostly mostly female
mostly female comedians Melissa
Villasenor I didn't bang her but I
jerked off in front of her in a hotel
room yeah good enough
still intimate yeah I wonder if girls
would uh is that bad for grit like you
know if you were like hey no I mean like
I know if you spring it on them but if
you were like hey do you want to come
over and just watch me jerk off I think
like would they be cool with it in
general or i mean i'd go like if some i
think you would get more people come on
over your apartment than you think you
would with that one let's look on
craigslist see if anybody's looking for
now girls aren't looking for them no no
looking for a look at why are you sure
Randy see if who anyone no I don't think
people post things looking for a look
alike cuz well let's call a look-alike
agency and tell them that we look like
people I don't think it would get anyone
on the phone I've done some extensive
research on look-alikes and there's no
numbers it's it's a lot of really old
looking websites and my ex-girlfriend
worked for one of these look-alike
thanks yeah she was she was Angelina
Jolie but shoot early I mean she was
keyboard is this who the [__] is this Oh
who is this who the [__] is this how'd
you get this how'd you get this how are
you talking to us right now who the [__]
is this hello I'm sorry who the [__] is
this the cop oh [__] yeah suck a dick
suck a dick it's okay eat [__] eat [__]
Randy you know what you do buy yourself
a real mood you know like oh my god you
know what I make more in five minutes
than you may call [__] year by battle
behind your face cops hello
whoo
Oh
[__] you shove lucu you dick
[__] anyway
uh
Oh
suck a dick
give her that song song but the coyotes
coyotes and they go you go with me
what's that song that song called a
cowboy song the coyote may be leaving oh
do you guys know they found a big like
super structure circling the stars are
you choose universe road diverse no yeah
yeah yeah it's like a super structure a
little thing le le le ins dude it's
gotta be you guys be with you or any
direction or any election
look
his face was